meanwhile though we have some of these
fake problems meanwhile the worst
villains on earth are getting away
literally with murder and this ties in a
little bit with what we were talking
about earlier about the written law
versus the real law Planned Parenthood
just got caught breaking the law and
then lying under oath about whether or
not they broke the law Planned
Parenthood we remember this from a few
years ago Planned Parenthood sold the
body parts of aborted babies for cash we
know they did that that is against the
law that's against 42 u.s. code 289 g2
which broadly forbids the exchange of
valuable consideration for fetal tissue
first videos came out five years ago you
might remember them it's Planned
Parenthood executives haggling with
investigative journalists who are
pretending to be procurers of baby body
parts haggling over the price one of
them joking that she wants a Lamborghini
what would you expect for intact tissue
what sort of compensation what sort of
the one you start by tell me what you
used to pay you no negotiations a person
throws up the finger first I lost mine
sir
oh she's so droll she just wants a
Lamborghini and she knows the first
person who throws out a dollar a number
in a negotiation that's the person who
loses in the negotiation by the way to
buy the body parts of babies that
they've killed so Planned Parenthood
initially denied this even though it was
on camera they denied this I know that
seems crazy but they just went on TV
flat-out denied it they sued the
journalist to expose them for millions
of dollars then a judge who was on the
board of a Planned Parenthood
ruled against the journalist gosh how
convenient is that wonder why he might
have made that decision the Planned
Parenthood claim at that point was that
they didn't actually sell the body parts
for money sure they sold body parts and
they got money for it but actually that
money was just a reimbursement for the
costs of giving away the body parts to
medical research here's then president
of Planned Parenthood Cecile Richards
making this claim and lying through her
teeth Washington Post calls Michael
Gerson has pointed out the charging a
fee for this for this material doesn't
matter fee it's not a fee it's actually
just the cost of transmitting this
material okay that's her story and she's
sticking to it she made this claim in a
lot of other places so knowing that
Planned Parenthood was gonna lie through
their teeth about this the journalists
behind all of this was a friend of mine
David daleiden he emails Planned
Parenthood documents outlining specific
costs for the body parts so not just
saying okay you're gonna reimburse us
for the costs of or we're gonna
reimburse you rather for the costs of
getting these parts no actual dollar
amounts for fetal liver for the thymus
right four different different parts
specifically by the way we're talking
about usable parts so it's not even just
for getting the parts and then if you
can't use them too bad they are
procuring usable parts just like when
you make a purchase from a department
store and then you know if the product
doesn't work you can go and return it or
not pay for the product same thing here
Planned Parenthood insisted then to keep
the lies going to the New York Times
that they rebuffed a contract to sell
aborted baby livers for 750 bucks each
and $1600 for liver and thymus
pairs however the head of Planned
Parenthood Gulf Coast tram noyon now
reveals that she was in fact looking to
move forward with the deal so so right
even after they get caught with the
dollar amounts they say look we never
actually engaged in the deal we had no
intention of engaging with the deal
we now have her under oath saying she
was moving forward with the deal at just
one affiliate Planned Parenthood Mar
Monte the clinic took in 25 grand in
just three months by selling away at
baby body parts here is tram moyen under
oath admitting what she did says that
the fee to claim permanent Gulf Coast
for a fetal liver would be $750 and the
fee for a fetal liver and the thymus
would be $1600
[Music]
this is an email chain
between you and oh nine t12 who is the
regional medical and surgical services
director what we understand as Dian
Santos is that your understanding do you
say F we are fYI we're still trying to
move forward with this she responds to
you and says do you want to do this you
respond to her and say yes ma'am do you
remember that exchange goddess why
yesterday
so you wanted to move forward with the
contract we just saw those price terms
connection was characterized the
document miscarriage is the testimony I
think I know I wanted to move forward
with it I know I wanted to move forward
with it we have her admitting it we have
them under oath we have it in writing we
have the dollar numbers we've got these
guys dead to rights violating the law
but this gets to this point earlier
earlier on this gets to this point about
big tech and so many other facets of our
politics Planned Parenthood is probably
not going to be held accountable do you
think Planned Parenthood's gonna be held
accountable for this no way actually
probably the journalist is is gonna
continue to get in trouble the
journalists probably gonna be forced to
pay millions of dollars have his life
thrown into chaos even more so because
there's the law as it's written down and
then there's the practical law is the
Constitution as it's written down then
there's the practical Constitution and I
think sometimes even people on the right
get a little too confused about this
they get really worked up because they
say look the law is so clear look I can
point to the law sure who's going to
enforce it who's going to enforce it
Planned Parenthood commits crimes
against humanity crimes against the
natural law crimes against the actual us
code crimes every single day many many
many times a day
they don't get in trouble for it because
we as a society have chosen to embrace
them through ridiculous Supreme Court
decisions multiple Supreme Court
decisions through ignoring parts of the
law and through going after people who
are exposing those violators of the law
that's that's an unfortunate reality but
that's the way politics always works
we're only going to go along with the
sort of laws that we want to go along
with right we are a self-governing
people we live in real real time and
space with real design
[Music]
[Music]